let's get some general impressions here
what do you mean how are you guys
feeling about Cory this might be yeah
might betray our heart is Hama and if
and if it is then Sony's presentation it
might be the best presentation you
cannot like to bring out like one game
is like that everyone's been looking
forward to this e3 we have had four
there's very few games that exist in the
realm of of like desire and speculation
that fall out for the last of us a final
fantasy 7 HD remake and then on top of
that like Shenmue 3 like what the fuckis
what rumors are like an arrival you
cycle i know there's no work Wow work
like this is crazy we shiet down all of
these games we looking forward to
forever like it's just absolutely insane
and it's insane that they are cashing
all those checks in one press conference
or in one show in the space of
twenty-four hours yeah it's about all
that is it we've had like a lot of good
conferences like let's not forget
microsoft conference was actually really
good yeah it's just that story just came
in it was just like we're just gonna
we're to event it's the end of the day
of the reporting cycle you know like
that work tomorrow is a new day after
you three new news coming but like for
me I think the highlight one the
highlight of the day I think for me is
still that hololens demo watching that
minecraft thing just captured my
imagination of like possibility and
creativity in the future of games in a
way that I was not like it's there I'm
optimistic about VR and all I stuff but
to see it like manifested so clearly
yeah and functioning yeah i think that's
that's why they really had the one up
over sony's that sony basically said
more fish than they were like oh this is
eSports for Morpheus but then didn't
really show ya anything but Microsoft
just laid it out in front of you and
just it was wonderful yeah good point
Morpheus was actually really scaled back
their show much at all they were I mean
we should have had a release day and a
prize which we didn't get which is
suspicious and kind of weird or even
just some like big heavy hitter games
like the no man's sky maybe beyond her a
bunch of Indies maybe they just haven't
had enough time because my I did cry
malvinas gamescom and Paris games week
which is a place to
position experience and Sony have said
they're going to have a big presence at
each of those so might as well save it
for them for them yeah well figure all
rights more Lucy Danny I'm sorry go
ahead Shamu tune out shenmue doin I my
browser says eight hundred and
forty-four thousand right dang yowza 31
days that's hope they reach it yep good
luck Shenmue 3 man if that game comes on
it sucks so unhappy no never want for
anything yeah